♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THERE IS A LOT OF NEWS GOING
ON AND WE'LL GET TO IT IN
JUST A MINUTE.
FIRST, A BIGGER STORY THAT
WE THINK WILL SHAPE THE
COUNTRY YOUR GRANDCHILDREN
WILL INHABIT MORE THAN ANY
OTHER.
THE NATION'S IMMIGRATION
LAWS ARE BREAKING DOWN
BEFORE OUR EYES.
THE PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
ENFORCING THOSE LAWS ARE
INSTEAD DESTROYING THEM.
YESTERDAY WE TELLING YOU
ABOUT CHICAGO, THE CITY OF
CHICAGO AND ITS NEW PLAN TO
GIVE I.D. CARDS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE OFFICIAL IDS WILL
ALLOW NONCITIZENS TO VOTE.
THAT'S AGAINST FEDERAL LAW.
NOT TO MENTION THE VERY IDEA
OF DEMOCRACY.
AMERICA IS SUPPOSED TO BE
RUN BY AMERICANS.
THAT'S THE POINT OF IT THE
POLITICIANS IN CHICAGO ARE
PUSHING TO SUBVERT THAT IF
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A
FOREIGN INFLUENCE SCANDAL
AND EVERYONE IN HERE IN D.C.
IS LOOKING FOR ONE.
YOU GOT IT.
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING IN
CHICAGO RIGHT NOW.
FOREIGN CITIZENS WILL BE
ELECTING OUR POLITICAL
LEADERS.
CHICAGO -- CAME ON THE SHOW
LAST NIGHT AND TRIED TO TELL
US IT WAS OUR IMAGINATION.
NONE OF THIS IS HAPPENING.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, HE SAID,
CAN'T VOTE BECAUSE IN
ILLINOIS YOU HAVE TO PROVE
YOU ARE A CITIZEN IN ORDER
TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
WATCH HIM TELL YOU THAT.
>> IN ORDER FOR SOMEONE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE, THEY WOULD
HAVE TO SIGN AN AFFIDAVIT
AND PRESENT A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE, A PASSPORT, A
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD AND
POTENTIALLY YOU STILL NEED A
SECOND FORM OF I.D.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SAYING IN
ORDER TO REGISTER TO VOTE IN
THE STATE OFISM KNOW, YOU
NEED TO PRODUCE EVIDENCE OF
CITIZENSHIP; IS THAT YOUR
CLAIM?
>> YES, IT IS.
>> Tucker: SO WE RARELY PLAY
TAPE OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ON THE SHOW WHEN THEY'RE NOT
HERE TO RESPOND BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE BAD SPORTSMANSHIP
YOU OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND DIRECTLY TO A CLAIM
AGAINST YOU BUT REPLAYING
THAT BECAUSE IT'S SO
PERFECTLY CRYSTALLIZES THE
DISHONESTY IN OUR PUBLIC
CONVERSATION ON THE SUBJECT.
YOU JUST HEARD AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL LOOK RIGHT INTO THE
CAM RAND TELL YOU A LIE.
NOT ONCE BUT THREE TIMES.
THAT'S NOT TRUE WHAT HE
SAID.
DO YOU NOT NEED PROOF OF
CITIZENSHIP TO REGISTER TO
VOTE IN THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS.
WE CHECKED.
EVERYONE WHO LIVES THERE
KNOWS THIS.
YOU JUST NEED PROOF OF
ANDREAS AND AN I.D., EXACTLY
LIKE THE ONE THE CITY OF
CHICAGO IS GIVING AWAY TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE IS ENCOURAGING THEM TO
TAKE.
INFORMED PEOPLE WHO SAY
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THAT ARE
LYING AND THEY ARE LYING
BECAUSE THEY WANTS ILLEGAL
ALIENS TO VOTE BUT THEY
DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT
IT OR COMPLAIN.
THAT IS CALLED FRAUD.
MEANWHILE, IN OAKLAND,
CALIFORNIA, MAYBE MAYOR
LIBBY SCHAAF HAS TAKEN THE
SIDE OF ILLEGAL ALIENS OVER
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
MAYBE TO HER CREDIT SHE IS
DOING IT RIGHT OUT IN THE
OPEN.
SHE IS TRYING TO SABOTAGE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
SHE ISSUED A PUBLIC WARNING
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
OAKLAND LAST WEEKEND.
SHE TOLD THEM OF AN
IMPENDING ICE RAID SO THEY
COULD GO INTO HIDING AND
AVOID FEDERAL AGENTS.
LIKE TELLING BANK ROBBERS
THE COPS ARE ON THE WAY.
WHO IS SHE PROTECTING BY
DOING THAT?
WE HAVE BRAND NEW NUMBERS ON
THAT QUESTION.
ACCORDING TO INFORMATION
SUPPLIED TO THIS PROGRAM BY
ICE, 864 ILLEGAL ALIENS,
CRIMINAL ALIENS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS REMAIN AT
LARGE IN OAKLAND.
THESE ARE EXACTLY THE
PEOPLE, THE MAYOR IS WARNING
BEFORE THE AUTHORITIES GET
THERE WE WILL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE EXAMPLES.
ONE IS A HONDURAN CITIZEN
ARRESTED MULTIPLE TIMES FOR
COCAINE TRAFFICKING AND
HAVING SEX WITH MINOR.
ANOTHER FROM MEXICO ARRESTED
AND CONVICTED FOR CARRYING A
LOADED GUN, FOR DUI, GUN
SMUGGLING.
BOTH OF THIEVES GUYS HAVE
BEEN DEPORTED FROM THE U.S.
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THEY HAVE COME BACK EVERY
TIME.
THEY HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO DO
THAT BECAUSE DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS WANT THEM TO
STAY HERE BECAUSE, YOU KNOW
THE ANSWER.
EACH ONE OF THESE PEOPLE, NO
POTENTIAL VOTE FOR THEM.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
DEMOCRATS HAVE GIVEN UP ON
MIDDLE CLASS.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO FIX
YOUR PROBLEMS.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY DON'T SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS.
THEY ARE NOT PRETENDING TO.
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF
FOREIGN VOTERS NOW.
MANY OF THEM ILLEGAL.
DEMOCRATS ARGUE FROM THE
HOUSE FLOOR THAT IMMIGRATION
LAW, THE LAW THEY PASSED BY
THEIR BODY, THE LAW MAKING
BODY, THOSE LAWS SHOULD BE
IGNORED OR NULLIFIED.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES ARE
SHOUTED DOWN WITH SLURS.
IT HAPPENS ON THIS SHOW ALL
THE TIME.
KEEPS HAS A PROOF OF
CITIZENSHIP FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION.
WHO WOULDN'T SUPPORT THAT?
NONCITIZENS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO VOTE FOR FEDERAL OFFICE.
PERIOD, IT'S FEDERAL LAW.
THE ACLU IS SUING.
DO YOU THINK THEY WILL SUE